Hi. It's Ira, recording this in 2006. This episode of our show, Episode 33, is one that actually never was broadcast nationally. We did a local broadcast of it in Chicago and always intended to go back to it and make it into a national version and never did. In fact, we don't even have a master copy of it, a digital recording of it. And what you're about to hear is actually from a cassette we have of the show, which is the only copy we can find. Anyway, here we go.
你好。我是Ira，这是我在2006年录制的。我们节目的这一集，即第33集，其实从未在全国范围内播出过。我们在芝加哥做过一次地方广播，一直打算回头把它做成全国版，但从未实现。事实上，我们甚至没有它的母带，也就是数字录音。你们现在听到的其实是我们手中仅存的一份录音带，这是我们能找到的唯一备份。总之，我们要开始了。
I don't remember when I first wandered into The Wieners Circle. I'm sure it was after midnight. I'm sure that, as always, the place was mobbed. I'm sure that, as always, people were screaming.
我不记得自己第一次走进Wieners Circle是什么时候了。肯定是在午夜之后。我很确定当时那里像往常一样挤满了人。我也很确定，像往常一样，人们在尖叫。
I need a veggie burger!
我需要一个蔬菜汉堡！
Lady? Lady!
女士？女士！
Veggie burger, double cheeseburger and a fry.
蔬菜汉堡，双层芝士汉堡和一份薯条。
Char burger!
碳烤汉堡！
The front of the hot dog stand is filled with a swarm of people. When I first went, it was a weird mix of cops-- there was a lot of cops there-- drunk yuppie 20-somethings, working class people who work in the neighborhood. But what really got to me was the staff. There's one of these windows you can look through, they ask for your order through. And they're in a space so small you could not park a car back there.
热狗摊前挤满了人。我第一次去的时候，那里有一群奇特的组合：有很多警察——那里确实有很多警察——喝醉的二十几岁雅皮士，还有在附近工作的蓝领阶层。但真正让我震惊的是员工。有一个你可以向内窥视的窗口，他们通过那个窗口接你的订单。他们所在的空间非常狭窄，连停一辆车都停不下。
And it's hot. You can tell it's hot. There are deep fryers and grills pouring off heat. There's hot grease everywhere. And they are constantly bumping into each other, getting into each other's way. And all of them, all of them are screaming nonstop. It's a kind of work environment that makes you wonder only one thing. Why don't these people want to kill each other?
而且很热。你能感觉到那种热度。油炸锅和烤架散发着热气。到处都是滚烫的油脂。他们不断地碰撞在一起，互相挡路。而他们所有人，所有的人都在不停地尖叫。这种工作环境让你不禁产生一个疑问：为什么这些人不想杀了对方？
I don't know. What does he got?
我不知道。他点了什么？
Stop being so miserable, you bastard.
别这么痛苦，你这个混蛋。
I don't know. What in the [BLEEP] did you order? That's all I'm asking. $2.30. That's all. Very easy. Now we'll get along. Now you can talk to me. [BLEEP]
我不知道。你到底点了什么？我只是在问这个。2.30美元。就是这样。很简单。现在我们可以好好相处了。现在你可以和我说话了。[消音]
But if you watch the workers at The Wieners Circle a little while more, you realize something else. They actually seem kind of happy. They're getting along. They kind of love each other. They joke around.
但如果你再多观察一会儿Wieners Circle的员工，你会意识到另一件事。他们实际上看起来挺开心的。他们相处得很好。他们似乎有点爱对方。他们会开玩笑。
I thought, whoever manages this place really knows how to run a restaurant. I mean, they're taking a job that seems like one of the hardest, most grinding physically and psychologically, on your feet all day, yelling backwards and forwards, and somehow they have turned it into a job that the people there actually seem to kind of like.
我想，管理这个地方的人真的很懂得如何经营餐馆。我的意思是，他们从事着一份看起来最艰苦、无论是体力上还是心理上最折磨人的工作，整天站着，来回叫喊，但不知何故，他们把它变成了一份那里的人似乎真的有点喜欢的工作。
I have more respect for this job than I can say almost any job that I've ever had. And I've had a lot of jobs.
我对这份工作的尊重，超过了我曾做过的任何一份工作。而我做过很多份工作。
You want to be here. It's like you're not working for money. You want to be here for real.
你想待在这里。这就像你不是为了钱而工作。你是真心想待在这里。
Come on.
来吧。
Yeah, I'm serious.
是的，我是认真的。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, a night at The Wieners Circle. I was there from 9:00 at night until dawn a couple Saturday nights ago. I saw hundreds of screaming drunks. A guy walked in who'd been carrying a statue of Zeus from one bar to the next. I saw a couple meet and flirt and get together. The staff cursed out the patrons. They cursed, sang them songs. Sometimes they sang them songs, mysteriously I should say, in Hebrew. What else happened? A man exposed himself to the women behind the counter. At their request. And at the end of the evening, everybody agreed, for them, it had been a quiet night.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天我们的节目是：在Wieners Circle的一夜。几个星期前的周六晚上，我从晚上9点一直待到天亮。我看到了成百上千个尖叫的醉鬼。有个家伙带着一座宙斯雕像从一家酒吧晃到另一家酒吧。我看到一对男女相遇、调情并走到了一起。员工对顾客破口大骂。他们咒骂，还给他们唱歌。有时他们还会给他们唱歌，顺便说一句，非常神秘地用希伯来语唱。还发生了什么？一个男人在柜台后的女性面前暴露了自己。应她们的要求。而在晚上结束时，大家都同意，对他们来说，这只是一个平静的夜晚。
Each week on our show, of course, we invite a variety of writers and performers. And this week, our contributors gave us stories about working in the lovely food service industry, about fast food places, about meat. Anyway, stay with us.
当然，我们每周都会邀请各种作家和表演者来到我们的节目。本周，我们的撰稿人分享了关于在可爱的餐饮业工作的故事，关于快餐店的故事，关于肉类的故事。总之，请继续收听。
So let us go back now. I guess an elegant sound transition would've been a good idea there, but whatever. Let us go back now in time to a Saturday night. It is time to meet our cast of characters. There are Larry and Barry, the owners of The Wieners Circle. Larry's a 50-year-old man in Spandex pants when he works Saturday nights. He lives in the high-rise across the street from The Wieners Circle. That's on Clark Street, by the way, between Fullerton and Diversey. Larry lives on the lowest floor so he can see in.
那么现在让我们回到过去。我想在这里做一个优雅的过渡音效会是个好主意，但随它去吧。现在让我们回到过去，回到一个周六的晚上。是时候介绍我们的角色阵容了。那是Larry和Barry，Wieners Circle的老板。Larry是一个50岁的男人，周六晚上工作时穿着氨纶裤。他就住在Wieners Circle街对面的一栋高层建筑里。顺便说一下，那是在Clark街，位于Fullerton和Diversey之间。Larry住在最低层，这样他就能看到里面。
Barry is 41. Shot up from 180 pounds to 300 since they bought The Wieners Circle, from eating the mistakes, he says. In the last two years, he's lost 100 of those pounds. And sitting on the picnic tables in front of the hot dog stand, they laugh about all the excuses that employees used to get out of work or show up late over the course of years. And they're talking about this when right at that moment, their night shift grill man walks up.
Barry 41岁了。自从他们买下Wieners Circle后，体重从180磅飙升到了300磅，他说是因为吃了那些做错的食物。在过去两年里，他减掉了其中的100磅。当他们坐在热狗摊前的野餐桌上时，他们笑着谈论员工多年来为了逃避工作或迟到而编造的各种借口。他们正在谈论这个的时候，他们的夜班烤肉师傅刚好走过来。
Here comes one of our employees who was supposed to be in at 8:00. He's moseying in like nothing ever happened. You're about to hear one of the excuses. This is Tony. Tell him why you were supposed to be here at 8:00 and you're here at 10:00.
我们的一位应该在8点上班的员工来了。他晃晃悠悠地走进来，好像什么都没发生过一样。你们即将听到借口之一。这是Tony。告诉他为什么你应该8点到，却在这个时候才来。
I'm sorry. But I got a flat tire, so--
对不起。但我轮胎爆了，所以……
See? That was one of the excuses. That's an old one. Thank you anyways, Tony.
看到了吗？这就是那些借口之一。那是一个老掉牙的借口。无论如何，谢谢你，Tony。
He doesn't even own a car.
他甚至都没有车。
Yeah, so that was--
是啊，所以那是……
The bus.
公交车。
The bus had the flat tire, I think. As you can see, we're not uptight about it.
我想是公交车轮胎爆了。如你所见，我们对此并不介意。
These guys are like the Car Guys, you know? I don't know if you're getting much sense of this. When they first opened The Wieners Circle 15 years ago, this is the sort of thing, showing up late, that they would fire people for. But they realized over time that it takes so long to train somebody that it just was not worth it for them to hire somebody new who then would have exactly the same number of late days and excuses and all that. So they have mellowed. They have mellowed over the years. And they view that as basically their experience, they told me.
这些人就像“汽车小子”，你知道吗？我不知道你们是否理解这一点。15年前他们刚开Wieners Circle时，迟到这种事是他们会开除员工的理由。但随着时间的推移，他们意识到培训一个人需要太长时间，雇一个新员工只会同样频繁地迟到和编造借口，所以这样做对他们来说不划算。于是他们变温和了。多年来他们变温和了。他们告诉我，他们认为这就是他们的经验所得。
On the Saturday night shift, there's also Vicky who is married to Barry, but refuses to work the same shift as Barry does. There's Noni on fries, Tony on the grill, Patricia and Freddie at the counter with Coffee. Coffee is a person, by the way. Coffee is a person whose real name is Pat, but she insists on Coffee because, as she will be the first to tell you--
在周六的夜班里，还有Vicky，她嫁给了Barry，但拒绝和Barry上同一个班。还有负责薯条的Noni，负责烤架的Tony，在柜台和Coffee在一起的Patricia和Freddie。顺便说一下，Coffee是个人。Coffee是一个真名叫Pat的人，但她坚持叫Coffee，因为正如她会第一时间告诉你的那样——
Because I grind so fine.
因为我磨得够细。
She's the backbone. Everybody asks for--
她是中坚力量。每个人都点名要——
You'll see her at her best, though, after midnight.
不过，午夜之后你才会看到她最棒的一面。
After midnight, baby. I'm good after midnight.
午夜之后，宝贝。午夜之后我才最厉害。
It is Coffee who sticks her long tongue out at men, on request and not. It is Coffee who can get the last word with any customer. It is Coffee, by the way, who accidentally cursed out Laurence Fishburne this week in the restaurant, not realizing who he was. The night I was there, a guy walked in at one point early in the night and says to Coffee and Patricia, who are standing behind the counter, "You work here?" And, of course, it's Coffee who says--
正是Coffee应要求或不应要求地向男人们吐出她那长长的舌头。正是Coffee能对任何顾客说出最后一句话。顺便说一下，正是Coffee这周在餐馆里不小心骂了Laurence Fishburne，因为她没认出他是谁。我待在那里的那天晚上，有一个家伙在晚上早些时候走进来，对站在柜台后面的Coffee和Patricia说：“你们在这里工作？”当然，是Coffee回答说——
Do you work here?
你在这里工作吗？
[BLEEP] no. We're just standing back here for decoration. What the [BLEEP] you thought?
去你的。我们只是站在这里当摆设。你觉得呢？[消音]
We just standing here because we like it.
我们站在这里只是因为我们喜欢。
What the [BLEEP] are you having?
你到底要点什么？[消音]
The guy sputters. Newcomers to The Wieners Circle late at night usually are not prepared for what they get. Regulars, on the other hand, come in all night and try to get the last word on Coffee and on everybody else. But especially on Coffee. Coffee's like-- you know those old Westerns where there's the gunslinger who's the top gun? That's Coffee. And that's the problem with being the top gun, if you remember your John Wayne movies. That's the problem with being the top gun. There's always somebody who thinks he's just a little quicker.
那家伙结结巴巴。深夜来到Wieners Circle的新手通常还没准备好迎接他们会遭遇的一切。另一方面，常客们整晚都会光顾，试图在Coffee和其他所有人身上占上风。但尤其是在Coffee身上。Coffee就像是……你知道那些旧西部片里枪法最好的枪手吗？那就是Coffee。而这就是成为顶级枪手的问题所在，如果你还记得你的John Wayne电影的话。这就是成为顶级枪手的问题。总有人觉得自己动作快那么一点点。
Being top gun. And that's exactly what it is, being top gun. If they can score, if they can score on me, then that's the whole thing. I mean, I feel like when I'll be here, I'm as famous as Michael Jordan, Dennis Rodman. Don't [BLEEP] with her! Don't [BLEEP] with her. [BLEEP] you, midget.
成为顶级枪手。事实确实如此，成为顶级枪手。如果他们能得分，如果他们能占到我的便宜，那就是重点。我的意思是，我感觉当我在这里时，我和Michael Jordan、Dennis Rodman一样出名。别惹她！别惹她。去你的，侏儒。
I have so much charming tape of them yelling at each other, like hours and hours of it. Coffee has four kids. The older ones have seen her cursing at The Wieners Circle and were shocked at first, she says. But then they understood that's just how she is at work. And she does have another job, she told me.
我有太多他们互相大喊大叫的迷人录音了，有几个小时之久。Coffee有四个孩子。她说，大一点的孩子刚开始看到她在Wieners Circle骂人时很震惊。但后来他们理解了，这就是她工作时的样子。她还有另一份工作，她告诉我。
I teach preschoolers, believe it or not.
信不信由你，我教的是学龄前儿童。
Over the course of a Saturday night these days, The Weiners Circle is mostly filled with yuppies, yuppie 20-somethings, seriously drunk. It is not an attractive sight. The women behind the counter call each other and themselves "bitch" mostly, as in--
如今，在一个周六的晚上，Wieners Circle里大多挤满了喝得大醉的雅皮士和二十几岁的年轻人。这可不是什么好看的景象。柜台后的女性大部分时间称呼对方和自己为“婊子”，就像——
Tell the black bitch as many times as she needs to know.
告诉那个黑人婊子她需要知道的一切。
There are not many settings in our mostly segregated city of Chicago where you can see a room of mostly white jock-like boys screaming insults, yelling bitch at women, sometimes actually throwing money, literally throwing dollar bills at a group of mostly non-white women and men. Coming to The Wieners Circle drunk, they have license to talk and act like they talk and act nowhere else.
在我们这个大多处于种族隔离状态的城市芝加哥，很少有地方能让你看到一屋子大多像运动员一样的白人男孩尖叫着侮辱人，对着女性大喊“婊子”，有时甚至真的扔钱，字面上就是把美元钞票扔向一群大多是非白人的男女。带着醉意来到Wieners Circle，他们获得了在其他地方绝不会有的话语权和行为许可。
But when I ask Coffee about it, she says that she doesn't see any big racial edge to what goes on at her job. She likes most of her customers. She truly likes them. And she says they don't go over the line. She tells me this story about a white South African who came in and misinterpreted the license that was happening inside The Wieners Circle.
但当我问起Coffee这件事时，她说她并没有感觉到她的工作中存在什么严重的种族色彩。她喜欢大多数顾客。她是真的喜欢他们。她说他们并没有过线。她告诉我一个关于一个白人南非人的故事，他进来后误解了Wieners Circle内部发生的这种许可。
And he said to me, he said, "You black ass nigger. You don't talk like that to me. Do you know who I am?" And at first, when he first said it, OK, I was laughing it off. Because I always laugh it off. Like, if somebody say, "Hey, you black bitch," I say, "Thank you." Or "You a dirty--" I say, "Thank you." So I thought he was playing at first, until he said something that one of the customers knew that he was actually being prejudiced about. And what happened was two of the other white guys that usually come in jumped onto him and started to fight him.
他对我说，他说：“你这个黑鬼。你不能那样跟我说话。你知道我是谁吗？”起初，当他第一次说的时候，好吧，我只是把它当成玩笑。因为我总是把它当成玩笑。比如，如果有人说，“嘿，你这个黑人婊子，”我说，“谢谢。”或者“你这个肮脏的——”我说，“谢谢。”所以我起初以为他在开玩笑，直到他说了一些顾客中有人知道他实际上带有偏见的话。结果是另外两个平时光顾的白人家伙冲上去和他打了起来。
When they take their breaks, The Wieners Circle staff seem to actually like each other. At one point, I was talking to Vicky and Coffee. And as Coffee was talking, Vicky gently reached over and wiped some mustard off of Coffee's cheek. Friday and Saturday nights from midnight until 4:00, working The Wieners Circle has the intensity of working in an emergency room. Except, of course, it's about hot dogs. And The Wieners Circle staff has bonded the way that emergency room staffs bond. And at dawn, after screaming at each other all night long, I mean, it sounds really corny to say it, but they are really affectionate with each other. They have no anger left over.
当他们休息时，Wieners Circle的员工似乎真的很喜欢对方。有一次，我正在和Vicky和Coffee交谈。当Coffee说话时，Vicky温柔地伸手擦掉了Coffee脸颊上的一些芥末。周五和周六晚上从午夜到凌晨4点，在Wieners Circle工作有着在急诊室工作的强度。当然，除了它是关于热狗的。Wieners Circle的员工已经像急诊室员工一样建立了深厚的感情。在黎明时分，经过整晚的互相尖叫，我的意思是，说出来听起来真的很老套，但他们确实对彼此充满爱意。他们心里没有留下任何愤怒。
If you ask the customers why they come here, most of them say it is the food and the employees. Or as one man put it, very concisely I thought, "It's dinner and a show." And some of the staff view it as a show also. And they say that if they weren't putting on a show, this would just be another food service job. Freddy, for example, said that he has worked the days at The Wieners Circle. And during the day, there's none of this acting up. There's none of the screaming. It is a normal hot dog stand that you can take your kids to. And Freddy said it's hard to bear. The hours drag by. It is not much fun at all.
如果你问顾客为什么来这里，大多数人会说是因为食物和员工。或者正如一个人非常简洁地总结道：“这是晚餐加表演。”一些员工也认为这是一种表演。他们说，如果他们不是在表演，这就会是另一份普通的餐饮工作。例如，Freddy说他在Wieners Circle上过白班。而在白天，没有这种胡闹。没有尖叫。这是一个普通的你可以带孩子去的热狗摊。Freddy说那很难熬。时间过得非常慢。一点意思都没有。
It's like, you'll say, please, thank you, have a nice day, and all that. And during the night, it's a bunch of drunks. And it's like playing all night, playing all night.
就像，你会说，请，谢谢，祝你有愉快的一天，诸如此类。而在晚上，是一群醉鬼。就像整晚都在玩，整晚都在玩。
And so if you couldn't scream, it would just be another job.
所以如果你不能尖叫，那就会是另一份工作。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
Now, I have something to confess to you, my beloved radio listeners. Though I have really amazing tape of other things which happened that night at The Wieners Circle, tape of Vicky and Patricia and Larry and the staff. And then some of the customers who really had some stories to tell, I have to say. Including-- this is a hot dog stand, oddly, haunted by David Schwimmer, for reasons I can't even begin to imagine.
现在，我得向你们这些亲爱的广播听众坦白一件事。虽然我确实有那天晚上在Wieners Circle发生的其他事情的精彩录音，有Vicky、Patricia、Larry和员工的录音。还有一些顾客确实有一些故事要讲，我必须说。包括——奇怪的是，这是一个被David Schwimmer困扰的热狗摊，原因我甚至无法想象。
There's also just stuff which happened, and without going into details, I will just say that those parts of the story did not get completed for tonight's show but will be completed, not for this coming Saturday, when we're talking about the Democrats, but the Saturday after that. You can hear this and more, more, more, a much more vivid little story. So listen to our little show for that, OK? Because there's a lot more to say about The Wieners Circle than I'm saying right now. And I want to share it with you.
还有一些发生的事情，我就不细说了，我只想说故事的那些部分并没有为今晚的节目完成，但会完成，不是在这个即将到来的谈论民主党人的周六，而是下下个周六。你可以听到这些以及更多、更多、更多，一个更加生动的小故事。所以请听我们的小节目，好吗？因为关于Wieners Circle还有很多话要说，比我现在说的要多得多。我想与你们分享。
[MUSIC - "HOT DOG" BY CHRIS POWELL]
[音乐 - Chris Powell的“HOT DOG”]
Act Two, The Customer. Well, of course, the relationship between staff and customers at The Wieners Circle is not your typical relationship between restaurant staff and restaurant worker. And for a more typical story, we turn to Beau O'Reilly, who not only is a playwright and a frequent contributor to our show, but he actually works at a restaurant, has worked at many restaurants, and has this story of a possibly recognizable restaurant in our possibly recognizable Chicagoland area.
第二幕，顾客。好吧，当然，Wieners Circle员工与顾客之间的关系，并不是典型的餐厅员工与服务对象之间的关系。对于一个更典型的故事，我们转向Beau O'Reilly，他不仅是一位剧作家，也是我们节目的常客，而且他实际上就在一家餐厅工作，做过许多餐厅的工作，并且在这个可能可以辨认出的芝加哥地区，有这样一个关于可能可以辨认出的餐厅的故事。
In our restaurant, restaurant workers give out new names to favorite customers or-- and this is a much bigger category-- favorite customers to hate and be bugged by. And the names usually come from restaurant habits-- 5:00 Window Seat Lady, Mr. Saturday Night, Two Ashtray Al-- or more potently and likely to stick forever, favorite food orders. The Scone Man always has one, a scone, and it's always well done. He's a favorite with a spot on the restaurant worker's heart because of his consistency. The Is There Wheat In This Lady who always brings a shudder of annoyance so deep that the restaurant worker feels he must be suffering a stroke or a brain aneurysm.
在我们的餐厅，餐厅员工会给最喜欢的顾客起新名字，或者——这是一个更大的类别——给最讨厌和最受困扰的顾客起名字。名字通常来自餐厅习惯——5点窗边女士、周六先生、两个烟灰缸的Al——或者更有效、更可能永远留下的名字：最喜欢的食物订单。“司康饼人”总是点一样东西，司康饼，而且总是要求全熟。因为他的稳定性，他在餐厅员工心中占有一席之地。那位总是让人感到一阵深层厌恶、让餐厅员工觉得自己一定患了中风或脑动脉瘤的“这里面有小麦吗女士”。
"Is there wheat in this? What about the soup? Is there wheat in it? The lasagna, is there wheat in it? The bread, is there wheat it it? I can't have wheat. Can I have half a bowl? Not the medium bowl, a tiny bowl. Can I have it to go? I can't eat it here. Can you double wrap it? Can you heat it on the stove? I can't have it microwaved. I can't have microwaves. Can I have some water while I wait? Is there wheat in this water?" The restaurant worker has been known to lock the door when he sees the Is There Wheat In This Lady coming.
“这里面有小麦吗？汤呢？里面有小麦吗？千层面，有小麦吗？面包，有小麦吗？我不能吃小麦。我可以要半碗吗？不是中碗，是一小碗。可以打包吗？我不能在这里吃。你能双层包装吗？你能在炉子上加热吗？我不能吃微波炉加热的。我不能用微波炉。等的时候可以给我点水吗？这水里有小麦吗？”餐厅员工看到“这里面有小麦吗女士”走来时，甚至会锁上门。
The Mustard Man is more deserving of pity, and the restaurant worker is aware of this. The Mustard Man is a limo driver who has gone legally blind, and he's probably harmless when he's not behind the wheel. He's pursuing a new line of work now, but like a middle-aged fat man pursuing a spot on the Olympic decathlon team, a new line of work may be outside his reach. The Mustard Man studies podiatry at the foot school across the street from where the restaurant worker works. The Mustard Man is a near member of that school's graduating class for the seventh time.
“芥末人”更值得同情，餐厅员工也意识到了这一点。芥末人是一名已经在法律上失明的豪华轿车司机，只要他不坐在驾驶座上，他可能就无害。他现在正在寻求一份新工作，但就像一个中年胖子追求奥运会十项全能比赛的名额一样，一份新工作可能超出了他的能力范围。芥末人在餐厅员工工作地点对面的足科学校学习足病学。芥末人已经是该校第七次进入毕业班的准毕业生了。
Before The Mustard Man became The Mustard Man, he was that guy from the school who offers to rub your feet, especially if your feet were lovely and your gams were shapely. He would offer to work on your foot without batting an eye, as if he were asking you to pass the ketchup. And his food orders were almost normal back then. Almost normal, but broken up and oddly shaped. Soup, soup must be served first, but soup always served cold until the restaurant worker anticipated it being served that way, and then he, The Mustard Man, would send it back with the instructions to nuke it until boiling. And when that soup was bubbling like a lava flow out of Mount Vesuvius, The Mustard Man would dump ice into it just to cool it back down.
在芥末人成为芥末人之前，他是学校里那个主动提出为你足部按摩的家伙，特别是如果你的脚很美且小腿匀称的话。他会提出为你按摩脚而眼睛都不眨一下，就好像他在请你递番茄酱一样。那时的他的订单几乎是正常的。几乎正常，但断断续续，形状古怪。汤，汤必须先上，但汤总是上凉的，直到餐厅员工预料到他会那样点，然后他，芥末人，又会把它退回来，要求把它加热到沸腾。当那碗汤像维苏威火山流出的熔岩一样冒泡时，芥末人又会把冰块倒进去把它冷却。
Desserts were worried over with hopes that the dessert at least would be included for free, forks exchanged randomly for extra spoons, knives sent back to the dishwasher, extra napkins, extra bread, extra, extra, extra. And every little variation of the dinner order was announced with an increased urgency that pretended towards the matter of fact. The Mustard Man's ordering technique seemed designed to ask the restaurant worker to pay attention to him as many times as possible. And the longer The Mustard Man came to the restaurant, gradually he increased his visits from once a week to three or four times a week.
甜点总是让人担心，希望甜点至少能免费提供，叉子被随机换成额外的勺子，刀子被退回给洗碗工，还要额外的餐巾、额外的面包，额外的，额外的，额外的。晚餐订单的每一个小变动都以一种假装事不关己的紧迫感宣布。芥末人的点餐技巧似乎旨在让餐厅员工尽可能多地关注他。随着芥末人来餐厅的次数增加，他逐渐将访问频率从每周一次增加到每周三四次。
The more the restaurant worker's trips to The Mustard Man's tables had to be increased, the restaurant worker took on a permanent look of vexation and rage that only The Mustard Man seemed not to notice. Other customers, they withered from that look. Their bold orders for whole meals were reduced to weak pleas for cups of tea and mumbled requests to use the phone. The idea of putting even one more straw on this restaurant worker's back by ordering real food was too much for these sensitive souls.
餐厅员工去芥末人桌子的次数不得不增加，员工脸上带着一种永久的厌烦和愤怒，似乎只有芥末人没注意到。其他顾客在那种表情下都畏缩了。他们本来大胆的点整餐的要求，减少成了虚弱的几杯茶请求和含糊不清的打电话要求。在这种餐厅员工的压力下，仅仅为了点真正的食物而给他们增加哪怕一根吸管的想法，对这些敏感的灵魂来说都太过分了。
But not The Mustard Man. The Mustard Man continued his barrage. More water, warm not hot. Fresh oregano. Mint toothpicks. Fresh bowls. As the weeks went on, The Mustard Man seemed to settle in, and he began to feel at home. He started table hopping. And usually, the other tables, they were filled with other near-graduates of the podiatry school, most of whom learned the mysteries of the human foot in a short one or two years.
但芥末人不是。芥末人继续他的攻势。更多的水，要温的不要热的。新鲜牛至。薄荷牙签。新鲜的碗。随着几周过去，芥末人似乎安顿了下来，开始感到宾至如归。他开始串桌。通常，其他的桌子都坐满了足科学校的其他准毕业生，他们大多数人在短短一两年内就学会了人类足部的奥秘。
And in our restaurant, The Mustard Man's table hopping, that was not acceptable. The students would cringe with disapproval as he approached them, declaiming the science of feet in a loud voice and manically grabbing at any unprotected Birkenstocks in a compulsive need to work on your foot, work on your foot. But The Mustard Man was crafty. He would rotate his table hopping so no one student group had too much cause to complain.
在我们的餐厅，芥末人的串桌是不可接受的。学生们在他接近时会因为不满而畏缩，他大声地宣讲足部科学，并强迫性地抓住任何毫无防备的勃肯鞋，有一种想要为你按摩脚、按摩脚的冲动。但芥末人很狡猾。他会轮流串桌，这样没有任何一个学生群体有太多的理由去抱怨。
The restaurant worker's annoyance was growing. Indeed, it had passed rage now, and it had moved into a gibbering, idiot hatred that worked on his brain. That's the thing about restaurants, working in restaurants. The workers hate the customers. It's an unnatural relationship. You're there to serve them. Why should you serve them?
餐厅员工的烦恼在增长。实际上，它已经超越了愤怒，转变成了一种在他大脑中运作的喋喋不休的白痴仇恨。这就是餐馆，在餐馆工作就是这样。员工讨厌顾客。这是一种不自然的关系。你待在那里是为了服务他们。你为什么要服务他们？
Until one day, The Mustard Man met the restaurant worker at the door as the restaurant worker was opening our restaurant for the evening. And he seemed particularly happy, The Mustard Man, reciting the entire menu aloud as the restaurant worker busied himself making coffee in a feeble attempt to ignore The Mustard Man.
直到有一天，当餐厅员工为晚间开门时，芥末人在门口遇到了他。芥末人似乎特别高兴，大声背诵整个菜单，而餐厅员工忙着煮咖啡，试图以一种无力的姿态忽略芥末人。
The door opens, and in walks a potential performer. Now, his voice is just quivering with excitement at the possibility of using the place for avant garde karaoke or contact wild turkey improvisation parties, something. His eyes speak of wild parties, wild turkey and more. His voice gets loud and rapid firing questions. And the restaurant worker puts him off, insisting on an appointment at a later date, a demo tape, a blueprint proposal, at another time. Right now, the restaurant worker, he's running a pot of coffee. And that coffee requires a lot of attention.
门开了，一个潜在的表演者走了进来。现在，他的声音因为使用这个地方进行先锋卡拉OK或接触狂野火鸡即兴派对的可能性而颤抖。他的眼睛里闪烁着疯狂派对、狂野火鸡和更多东西的光芒。他的声音变得响亮且迅速地提出问题。餐厅员工推开了他，坚持要求在以后的日期预约，要一个试听带、蓝图提案，在另一个时间。现在，餐厅员工正在煮一壶咖啡。而那咖啡需要很多关注。
And The Mustard Man, he jumps up to help. He's taking the potential performer on a tour of the restaurant worker's restaurant, our restaurant. The lovely stage and the handsome tablecloths and the cheerful crockery. And the two of them are constructing a loud Tower of Babel that has the restaurant worker seething now. And as The Mustard Man finally escorts the potential performer out the door, shouting "We'll get back to you with an offer."
而芥末人，他跳起来帮忙。他带着那个潜在的表演者参观了餐厅员工的餐厅，我们的餐厅。可爱的舞台、漂亮的桌布和欢快的餐具。他们俩正在搭建一座吵闹的巴别塔，让餐厅员工现在怒火中烧。当芥末人终于把那个潜在的表演者送出门外时，喊道：“我们会给你一个报价。”
"An offer of what?" fumes the restaurant worker.
“报价什么？”餐厅员工怒气冲冲。
The Mustard Man gives the potential performer one last longing look, glancing down at the potential performer's wingtips and wondering about the feet that they might hold. And then the restaurant worker lets him have it. Inappropriate, spew. Boundary issues, spew. Spew, spew. Attention monger, spew. Self-involved juvenile, spew, spew. Inappropriate, inappropriate, inappropriate behavior, spew! The restaurant worker, expanding and puffed-up like a porcupine on defense. And The Mustard Man, shrinking and inappropriate now, is backing out the door.
芥末人给了潜在的表演者最后深情的一瞥，扫了一眼潜在表演者的牛津鞋，想着里面可能藏着的双脚。然后餐厅员工对他爆发了。不恰当，喷出。边界问题，喷出。喷，喷。寻求关注者，喷出。以自我为中心的少年，喷出，喷出。不恰当，不恰当，不恰当的行为，喷出！餐厅员工，像一只防御状态的豪猪一样膨胀起来。而芥末人，现在缩小了，感到不适，正退出门外。
The Mustard Man didn't stop coming to our restaurant. He still appeared regularly. But now he never sat, he never table-hopped, ordering only bread gobbed with mustard to go. He became The Mustard Man. "Bread with mustard to go, please," in a clear but subdued voice.
芥末人没有停止来我们的餐厅。他仍然经常出现。但现在他从不坐下，从不串桌，只点涂了芥末的面包打包。他成了芥末人。“涂芥末的面包打包，谢谢，”声音清晰但低沉。
And the restaurant worker never spoke personally to him again. Things were ice between them, professional, appropriate. And sometimes The Mustard Man wouldn't even come in. The restaurant worker would look up from strangling a fruit salad or burning a bagel to death and see The Mustard Man, his face pressed against the restaurant window like the restaurant was a new pair of Converse high-tops and the restaurant worker a wondrous pair of feet The Mustard Man would love to get his hands on. And the restaurant worker thought The Mustard Man looked particularly bad with his face pressed against the window like that.
此后餐厅员工再也没有私下和他交谈过。他们之间变得冷淡，专业，得体。有时芥末人甚至不会进来。餐厅员工会从挤压水果沙拉或把百吉饼烧焦中抬起头，看到芥末人，他的脸压在餐厅窗户上，就像餐厅是一双全新的匡威高帮鞋，而餐厅员工是一双芥末人非常想抓到手里的奇妙双脚。餐厅员工觉得芥末人把脸压在窗户上的样子特别丑。
Beau O'Reilly's running the Rhino Fest and he works at The Lunar Cabaret restaurant.
Beau O'Reilly正在运营Rhino节，他在The Lunar Cabaret餐厅工作。
Coming up on our program-- coming up, what is coming up? Coming up, hot dogs as metaphor for all politics in the city of Chicago and ever so much more as our little food program continues.
接下来是我们的节目——接下来，接下来是什么？接下来，热狗作为芝加哥乃至更多政治的隐喻，随着我们小小的食品节目继续进行。
Act Three, A Parable of Politics. Well, I'm joined now in the studio by one of the public radio reporters here in Chicago, Shirley Jahad. Welcome to our studio.
第三幕，政治寓言。好吧，现在和我一起在录音室的是芝加哥的公共广播记者之一，Shirley Jahad。欢迎来到我们的录音室。
Hi there, Ira.
你好，Ira。
And Shirley, you've agreed to do a little assignment for us, because hot dogs in Chicago are not just food. They are a lens through which we can see the workings of our great city. And I know that you have a story here of a company that did everything it was supposed to, here in the city that works, to grease the skids and see that things went well, and ran into some trouble and finally-- well, we'll say whether they prevailed or not as the story proceeds. But why don't you explain who this company is?
Shirley，你已经同意为我们做一个小任务，因为在芝加哥，热狗不仅仅是食物。它们是一个透镜，通过它我们可以看到我们伟大城市的运作。我知道你这里有一个故事，关于一家公司，在这里这座运转良好的城市里，为了润滑关系并确保事情顺利进行，尽了他们应尽的一切努力，却遇到了一些麻烦，最终——好吧，随着故事的推进，我们会说他们是否获胜。但你为什么不解释一下这家公司是谁？
Well, that's right, Ira. We're talking about Chicago's own Vienna Beef Hot Dog. This is a very established company in the city, been here for more than 100 years. And like you said, they've done everything right. They employ 500 people in the city, they stayed in town when other people went to the suburbs, the head of the company, Jim Bodman, is a good corporate citizen, a contributor to all the right campaigns, including Mayor Daley's campaign, Mayor Richard Daley's campaign. He gives the maximum amount he can.
好的，没错，Ira。我们谈论的是芝加哥本土的Vienna Beef热狗。这是一家在这座城市非常有名的公司，已经在这里存在了100多年。就像你说的，他们做的一切都很对。他们在城里雇用了500人，当别人去郊区时他们留在了城里，公司负责人Jim Bodman是一位优秀的企业公民，也是所有正确竞选活动的捐助者，包括Daley市长，Richard Daley市长的竞选。他给出了他能给的最大金额。
Whenever City Hall calls, he says, he responds as much as he can. He sends hot dogs to the parks for kids. He's even contributing hot dogs to the big media party for journalists and delegates coming to the Democratic National Convention in Chicago. And every year, he contributes to the city's big summer party, the city's best summer festival, The Taste of Chicago. The city tries to draw in area residents and tourists from all around using this festival.
每当市政厅打电话来，他说，他都会尽可能响应。他送热狗到公园给孩子们吃。他甚至为即将在芝加哥举行的民主党全国代表大会的记者和代表们的大型媒体派对捐赠热狗。每年，他都会为城市的大型夏季派对，城市最好的夏季节日，“芝加哥美食节”做出贡献。这个城市试图利用这个节日吸引地区的居民和来自各地的游客。
And they ask us for money to help them do that. And we give them money. And they promise us that all the food that is served there will be our food, and they put our name up. It's a classic example of you scratch my back and I'll scratch your back. Pretty simple, and it works very well.
他们向我们索要钱来帮助他们做这件事。我们给他们钱。他们向我们保证那里供应的所有食物都将是我们的食物，他们会把我们的名字挂出来。这是一个典型的例子，你抓我的背，我也会抓你的背。很简单，而且效果很好。
So the guy's playing by the rules.
所以这家伙在按规则办事。
Everything's going just as it's supposed to.
一切都按照预想进行。
And now at this point, I can pick up the story a little bit. Because about a year ago, I just happened to be sitting in Jim Bodman's office at the Vienna Beef Sausage Company for reasons too complicated to go into here. And I'm sitting there and the phone rings, and it's somebody from the mayor's office. And they want 200 hot dogs for some event in some park for some kids. And Bodman says, "Sure, sure, sure." And then his voice goes kind of low. And he says, "Listen to me. Can you give me any help on this Navy Pier thing? They're killing me on this Navy Pier thing. And I don't understand it. I don't understand why we can't get our dogs out onto Navy Pier."
现在，在这一点上，我可以稍微接手这个故事。因为大约一年前，我刚好坐在Vienna Beef香肠公司Jim Bodman的办公室里，原因太复杂，这里就不展开了。我坐在那里，电话响了，是市长办公室的人。他们需要200个热狗，要在某个公园给孩子们办个活动。Bodman说：“没问题，没问题，没问题。”然后他的声音变得很低沉。他说：“听我说。你能帮我处理这个Navy Pier的事情吗？他们要把我在Navy Pier这件事上整死了。我不明白。我不明白为什么我们的热狗不能进Navy Pier。”
Ira, take us to Navy Pier. Hit that sound.
Ira，带我们去Navy Pier。放出那个声音。
All right. Let's hit the sound through the magic of radio.
好的。通过广播的魔法让我们听听那个声音。
[PIER AMBIENCE]
[码头环境音]
That was such a public radio moment, wasn't it?
那真是个典型的公共广播时刻，不是吗？
Here we are on Navy Pier, Ira. It's a wonderful place for summer fun. Carousels, Ferris wheels--
我们现在在Navy Pier，Ira。这是个夏天娱乐的好地方。旋转木马，摩天轮——
Watch out for that kid with that balloon, Shirley. [LAUGHTER] It's so realistic.
小心那个拿着气球的孩子，Shirley。[笑声] 这太逼真了。
There's a lot of shops, a lot of food, you know, the water and the boats and whatnot. It's called the jewel of Chicago's lakefront. It's this high-traffic showcase area.
有很多商店，很多食物，你知道，水和船等等。它被称为芝加哥湖滨的明珠。这是一个高人流量的展示区。
Tourists.
游客。
A lot of tourists, a lot of folks from the suburbs, a lot of kids--
很多游客，很多郊区来的人，很多孩子——
A lot of kids.
很多孩子。
--and grown ups. It cost $100 million of taxpayer money, bond money, to refurbish Navy Pier. And it was all carefully planned which businesses were going to go where.
——还有大人。 refurbish Navy Pier花了1亿美元的纳税人钱，债券钱。所有的商业安排都经过精心规划。
Now, Bodman told me that he couldn't get the dog out on Navy Pier. Did he bid on  the contract?
现在，Bodman告诉我他无法让热狗进入Navy Pier。他投标这个合同了吗？
Bodman bid $0.45 lower per pound for his dogs to be on Navy Pier, and he still didn't get the contract.
Bodman的热狗每磅报价低了0.45美元，但他还是没拿到合同。
That seems to me to be not the way things are done.
在我看来，这不像是做事的方式。
It's not the way things should have been done--
这不应该是做事的方式——
Here in Chicago.
在这里，在芝加哥。
--in Chicago.
不知何故，这个纽约热狗移民进了我们的后院。这并不是随机发生的。有人认识某个人，而那个人又认识某个人。他们说，让我们把Charlie's热狗弄进Navy Pier，我们会玩得很开心，因为它是一个非常公共的地方。不，这不是随机的。发生了什么。有人对某人说了什么，这就是世界运作的方式。
Somehow this New York hot dog migrated into our backyard. And it didn't happen by random occurrence. Somebody knew somebody who knew somebody. And they said, let's get Charlie's Hot Dogs into Navy Pier and we'll really have a big time with it because it's a very public place. No, it wasn't random. Something happened. Somebody said something to someone, and that's the way the world works.
这就是我们城市运作的方式。黑幕已经拉开了。
And that's the way our city works. The fix was in.
好吧，是的。他没有直说黑幕拉开了。他只是把话留在这里。我想这是芝加哥政治荣誉准则的一部分。你谁也不认识，谁也[？罪恶]。所以他并没有打算准确地告诉我那个认识某个人的人是谁。
Well, yeah. He doesn't quite say the fix was in. He just sort of leaves it at that. I guess it's part of the Chicago code of honor in politics. You don't know nobody, nobody [? sins. ?] So he wasn't going to exactly tell me who that somebody was who knew somebody.
他不告诉你？啊。他就是不告诉你？
He wouldn't tell you? Ah. He would not tell you?
他就是不说。
He would not say.
你知道那是谁吗？
Who was that, do you know?
不知道。
No.
那是码头工作人员吗？
Was it somebody who worked for the Pier?
如果我知道，我也不会告诉你。
And if I knew, I wouldn't tell you.
那是码头工作人员吗？
Was it someone who worked for the Pier?
我可能是一个热狗推销员，但我并不傻。
I might be a hot dog salesman, but I'm not stupid.
[笑声]
[LAUGHTER]
那是，像——你认为——
Was it, like-- do you think--
我不会告诉你的。略略略略略。
I'm not going to tell you. Nyah-nyah-nyah-nyah-nyah-nyah.
那是，那是，像——
Was it, was it, like--
我不知道。我不会告诉你的。
I don't know. I'm not going to tell you.
看，这是你在记者面前看不到很多大企业高管使用的策略，就是用假声嘲弄你。
See, there is a tactic you don't see many big corporate executives use with reporters, is just to mock you in a falsetto.
没错，Ira。他是一个很难攻克的人。你明白我的意思吗？他没有站出来告诉我名字。
That's true, Ira. He was a tough one to crack. You know what I'm saying? He wouldn't come forward and tell me the name.
好吧，这就是我们的制度。这就是我们在芝加哥的制度。所以你去了哪里？
Well, that's our system. That's our system here in Chicago. So where did you go?
所以当然，我们不得不把它带到市政厅。Bodman不开口，所以我们不得不去找我们的市政厅线人。当然，他们确实开口了，尽管是低声细语。我的意思是，他们不能自由地公开说一切。他们没有录音，之类的。但在录音外，我的市政厅线人确实和我谈论了关于Navy Pier热狗的整件事，以及它是如何发生的。为什么芝加哥的公司没能把他们的热狗弄上码头？
So of course we had to take it to City Hall. Bodman wasn't talking, so we had to go to our City Hall sources. And of course, they did talk, albeit in a whisper. I mean, they weren't free to say everything openly. They weren't talking on tape, or anything. But off tape, my City Hall sources did talk to me about this whole thing with the hot dogs on the Pier and how it really went down. How come the Chicago company didn't get their dogs on the Pier?
那么，他们有没有给你一个名字，那个人就是阻碍我们进入码头，阻碍我们本土热狗进入码头的人？他们给你名字了吗？
Now, did they give you a name of somebody who was the person who was keeping us off the Pier, keeping our homegrown dogs off the Pier? Did they give you a name?
我们没有名字。
We don't have a name.
我们还是没有名字。
We still don't have a name.
好的。那么我们有什么？
All right. Well, what do we have?
但我们确实有一些非常重要的信息。正如我们这一行所说，我们已经确认了。我们已经确认了。因为市政厅的线人已经向我证实，是的，芝加哥就是这样运作的。多年来一直如此，而且永远都会这样，他说。这不一定是最好的方式，但这就是现状。他对我说了，引用：“黑幕已经拉开了。”
But we do have some very important information. We do have confirmation, as we say in the business. We have confirmation. Because the City Hall source has confirmed to me that, yeah, this is how Chicago works. It's been this way for years and years and years, and it's always going to be this way, he says. It's not necessarily the best way, but it is the way it is. And he said to me, quote, "The fix was in."
我会说，鉴于Bodman每磅报价低了0.45美元却没拿到合同的事实，我会相信这一点。
I would say, actually, given the fact that Bodman bid $0.45 less a pound and didn't get the contract, I'd say that I would believe that.
你会相信。好的，那么我们已经确认了。“黑幕已经拉开了，”他说。然后他说，“人们需要被照顾。”这是他的话，不是我的。然后他停顿了一下。这就是有趣的部分。他停顿了一下。“人们需要被照顾，”他说，然后他停顿了。他说，“而且那不一定是一件腐败的事情。”
You would believe that. OK, well, we have confirmation. "The fix was in," he says. And then he says, "People need to be taken care of." These are his words, not mine. Then he paused, though. This was the interesting part. He takes a pause. "People need to be taken care of," he says, and he pauses. And he says, "And that's not necessarily a corrupt thing."
[笑声]
LAUGHTER]
在芝加哥就是这样，你知道吗？
That's how it is in Chicago, you know?
好吧，你知道。街道被铺好了。垃圾被收走了。那是件好事。
Well, you know. The streets are paved. The garbage is picked up. That's a good thing.
那是对的。
That's right.
所以人们需要被照顾。
So people need to be taken care of.
那是对的。而且——
That's right. And--
那么Bodman是——
Then Bodman is--
——Bodman绝对是——
--Bodman is absolutely--
他是那些人之一。
He's one of those people.
他是那些人之一。此时此刻，他真的觉得他需要被照顾。
He's one of those people. At this point, he really feels like he needs to be taken care of.
市长的捐助者。
Contributor to the mayor.
他觉得他在尽了一切正确的做法后被晾在了一边。他向市长的竞选活动捐款。他每当在市政厅被呼叫时都会赶来，诸如此类。
He feels like he's been left hung out to dry after he did everything right. He gives to the mayor's campaign. He comes whenever he's called at City Hall, and whatnot.
所以接下来是？
So next is?
所以当然，政治中接下来是什么？
So of course, what's next in politics?
开会。
A meeting.
绝对是。他们召集了一次会议。所有的参与者都聚在一起了。所以这是那些芝加哥风格政治会议的典型例子。你们都听说过，可能想象过，高权力，密室，烟雾缭绕——
Absolutely. They called a meeting. And all the players got together. And so this is one of those quintessential Chicago-style political meetings. You've all heard about them, maybe imagined them, high-powered, back room, smoke-filled--
我希望我能只看到——
I wish I could only see--
——雪茄。
--cigars.
——市长那天的时间表。“11点到11点半，热狗会议。”细节无小事。那么我们知道是谁参加了这个会议吗？
--the mayor's schedule for that day. "11:00 to 11:30, hot dog meeting." No detail too small. So what do we know about who was at this meeting?
好吧，你知道，关于到底是谁参加了会议，我们有相互矛盾的信息。我的市政厅线人告诉我市长实际上参加了会议，但当然——
Well, you know, we have conflicting information on exactly who was at the meeting. My City Hall source tells me the mayor was, in fact, at the meeting, but of course--
这个如此重要、权力巨大的热狗会议，他怎么可能错过？但Bodman坚持认为，不，市长不在那里。他有比处理这些“热狗问题”更重要的事情要做。这是Bodman的话，再次重申，不是我的。但谁在那里？所以谁在那里？所有这些来自Navy Pier的官员，Navy Pier的管理机构。
This all-important, high-powered hot dog meeting, how could he miss it? But Bodman insists, no, the mayor wasn't there. He has more important things to do than deal with these "weenie problems." Those are Bodman's words, again, not mine. But who was there? So who was there? All these officials from Navy Pier, the governing body of Navy Pier.
那是一个州立机构，大都会码头和会议管理局，或类似的名字。好的，一个州立机构。所以我们有来自州立机构的人，我们有市长。
That's a state agency, the Metropolitan Pier and Convention Authority, or some name like that. OK, a state agency. So we've got people from a state agency, we've got the mayor.
还有市长的助理和来自市长办公室的各种联络人。我们有Bodman和他的人。我们还有一些来自处理合同的餐饮公司的人——
And assistants to the mayor and all different kinds of liaisons from the mayor's office. And we have Bodman and his people. And we have some people from the catering company that deals with the contracts--
在码头上，对吧？
At the pier, right?
——在Navy Pier上。所以就像我们说的，这是一种，你知道——
--on Navy Pier. So like we say, it's one of those, you know--
你想象这种事情，你想象一种非常有权势、光鲜亮丽的事情。
And you picture this kind of thing, and you picture sort of a very high-powered glamorous sort of thing.
让我们听听Bodman是怎么说的。
Let's hear how Bodman tells it.
很有趣。房间里大约有15个人。就像学校董事会会议。你知道，每个人都喜欢听自己说话。
It was interesting. There were about 15 people in the room. It was like a school board meeting. You know, everybody likes to hear themselves talk.
我很高兴我不在那里。
I'm so glad I was not there.
那可能没那么令人兴奋。
It may have not been that exciting.
作为一个参加过许多学校董事会会议的人，我只想说。好吧，那他得到满意了吗？
As somebody who has been to many school board meetings, I just want to say. OK, so did he get satisfaction?
最后，Bodman说正义得到了伸张。现在你可以，亲爱的听众，如果你来到芝加哥，可以在Navy Pier买到你的Vienna Beef热狗。
In the end, Bodman says justice was served. And now you can, dear listener, get your Vienna Beef dog on Navy Pier if you come to Chicago.
正义是用芝麻汉堡胚供应的。
Justice was served on a sesame seed bun.
罂粟籽胚，亲爱的。
Poppy seed bun, my dear.
罂粟籽胚，抱歉。
Poppy seed bun, excuse me.
加辣味辣椒，谢谢。
With hot peppers, thank you.
好的。所以正义得到了伸张，你现在可以在Navy Pier买到热狗了。
All right. So justice was served, and you can get your dog on Navy Pier now.
你可以在Navy Pier买到热狗。这就是我们的城市。这是运作的城市。这是一个政治深入贯穿一切的地方。它在空气中。你甚至看不见它。
You can get your dog out on Navy Pier. That's our city. It's the city that works. It's a place where politics runs deep thick throughout everything. It's in the air. You can't even see it.
即使是热狗，你也得把它带到五楼。
Even hot dogs, you've got to take it to the fifth floor.
你必须把它带到市长办公室，没错。
You've got to take it to the mayor's office, that's right.
这就是我们谈论的内容。
That's what we're talking about.
Bodman说这只是生意。
And Bodman says this is just business.
这不是政治。只是生意。
It's not politics. Just business.
这不是政治。
It's not politics.
事实的真相是这只是一笔生意。他们在使用热狗，而我们不喜欢它们来自竞争对手的事实，这就是我们的经济体系运作的方式。你进入那里，你战斗，你请求，你乞求，你尽你所能做合法和道德的事情。你尝试获得业务。而这也是其他人试图做的事情。
The truth of the matter is that this is just a business deal. They were using hot dogs, and we didn't like the fact that they came from a competitor, and that's how our economic system works. You get in there and you fight and you ask and you beg and you do whatever you can do that's legal and moral. And you try to get the business. And that's what the other people are trying to do also.
我们是否利用政治人物来帮助我们进行那场斗争？打赌我们做了。我们打了市长的电话。如果Bill Clinton接电话，我也会打给他。因为如果你血管里流淌着一些竞争的血液，那就是你所做的。我们不需要Bill。我们需要Rich。而Rich是——
Did we use the political people to help us in that fight? You bet we did. We called the mayor. I would have called Bill Clinton had he answered the telephone. Because if you've got some competitive blood flowing in your veins, that's what you do. We didn't need Bill. We needed Rich. And Rich is--
Rich，我应该为家里的听众说明一下，Rich，当然，Rich Daley，我们的市长。
Rich, I should say for our listeners at home, Rich, of course, Rich Daley, our mayor.
——那个帮助我们的人。我们利用了他们。我们不经常利用他们，但这是我们利用他们的一次。但与其说是政治影响，不如说是向我们曾经帮助过的人寻求帮助。
--the guy who helped us. We used them. We don't use them very often, but this is one time that we did use them. But it was not political influence as much as it was just seeking help from people who we've helped before.
我只是想停在那里。如果那不是政治影响，那么如果不向曾经帮助过的人寻求帮助，政治又是什么？
I just want to stop the tape right there. If that is not political influence, what is politics if it is not seeking help from people who you have helped before?
听起来有点政治。
Sounds kind of political.
好吧。但并不是说有什么不对。并不是说有什么不对。
All right. But not to say there's anything wrong with that. Not to say there's anything wrong with that.
这都是合法的。
It's all legal.
这是合法的。
It's legal.
是的。公开的。
Yeah. Above board.
一切公开。好吧，这就是我们的城市。Shirley Jahad，感谢你帮助我们讲述这个关于运作城市的小寓言，以及它到底是如何运作的，以及它是如何延伸到最卑微的汉堡胚上的。
All above board. Well, there's our city right there. Shirley Jahad, thank you for helping us with this little parable of the city that works and exactly how it works and how it extends even down to the lowliest bun.
谢谢，Ira。
Thank you, Ira.
谢谢。你知道，我还应该感谢Dick Bodman，他真的没有好的理由跟我们交谈。那是一个体面人的标志。他实际上是我们电台的听众。那是一个慷慨的举动，我们很感激。
Thank you. You know, I should also say thanks to Dick Bodman who really had no good reason to talk to us. That is a sign of a decent person. And he's actually a listener to our radio station. It is a generous act, and we appreciate that.
第四幕，快餐心。关于快餐的一件事是，像我们文化中的其他一切一样，一切为了被丢弃而制作的东西，一切为了被处理掉而制作的东西，比如糟糕的电视节目，诸如此类，迟早我们变得如此喜欢它，它成为我们经验的深层部分。然后它基本上成为了我们是谁。
Act Four, Fast Food Heart. One of the things about fast food is, like everything else in our in our culture, everything that's made to be throw-away, everything that's made to be disposable, like bad TV shows, everything like that, sooner or later we become so fond of it and it becomes a deep part of our experience. And then it becomes basically who we are.
这是我在接下来一年里要在节目中说的最哲学的话。让我现在就说出来吧。总之，考虑到这一点，我们这里有一个由Cassandra Smith撰写的关于某种特定快餐和快餐店意义的故事。
That's the most philosophical thing I'm going to say on this show for the next year. Let me just say that right now. Anyway, so with that in mind, we have a story here by Cassandra Smith about the meaning of one particular fast food and fast food establishment.
在日本的第18天，我终于崩溃了。将近三周，我拒绝了所有西式食物。连一杯咖啡或一杯牛奶都没有。我拒绝了牛肉、白面包。我甚至放弃了嚼口香糖。
On the 18th day in Japan, I finally broke down. Nearly three weeks and I had refused all Western food. Not a cup of coffee or a glass of milk. I refused beef, white bread. I'd even given up chewing gum.
我的女房东很担心。“美式早餐？”她每天在我的生鱼或虾晚餐后问。她曾听过我深夜作呕和哭泣。“不，”我回答。我下定决心要像日本人一样生活和进食。海鲜、酱油和米饭。连糖果都是米做的。在第18天，我崩溃了。
My hostess was worried. "Breakfast American style?" she asked every evening after my dinner of raw fish or shrimp. She had heard me gagging and crying late at night. "No," I answered. I was determined to live and eat Japanese style. Seafood, soy sauce, and rice. Even the candy is made out of rice. On the 18th day, I cracked.
在京都的一条后街，热炸鸡的味道穿过空气。那是一首塞壬之歌，一个引导我像僵尸一样穿过狭窄街道的吹笛人。我跟着那浓郁、油腻的香气，发现，在面馆和寿司店之间，有一个安全的避风港。这里是日本京都的一条主干道上，隔壁是一家和服精品店，耸立着一个文明的前哨：一家肯德基。11种草药和香料的香气涌入夜晚的空气，经过正穿着盛装去上班的艺妓，以及带着外带寿司匆忙回家的职业女性。
On a back street in Kyoto, the smell of hot fried chicken sliced through the air. It was a siren song, a pied piper that led me zombie-like through the narrow streets. I followed the thick, greasy fragrance and found, jammed between the noodle shops and sushi bars, a safe haven. Here on a main street in Kyoto, Japan, next door to a kimono boutique, stood an outpost of civilization, a Kentucky Fried Chicken. The aroma of 11 herbs and spices pushed out into the evening air, past geishas on their way to work in full regalia and career girls rushing home with takeout sushi.
站在门口的是一尊五英尺高的桑德斯上校雕像。他全身雪白，手里拿着一根金顶拐杖。他的眼睛微微眯起，脸颊圆润红润，就像圣诞老人，但那是他，上校，右手举起象征和平。我冲了进去。进去后，我感受到一阵释然。熟悉的乙烯基卡座，菜单上上校微笑的脸，虽然那是日语，但我立刻就明白了。胸肉和翅膀、卷心菜沙拉和比斯吉饼。纸板盒像一个神奇的珠宝盒一样弹开。我咬下一口油腻的胸肉，发出了一声充满泪水的叹息。
Standing at the door was a five-foot statue of the Colonel. He was dressed all in white and holding a gold-tipped cane. His eyes were slanted and his cheeks round and red like Santa, but it was him, the Colonel, with his right hand raised in a sign of peace. I rushed inside. Once in, I felt a flood of relief. The familiar vinyl booths, the Colonel's smiling face over the menu, which even though it was in Japanese, I instantly understood. Breast and wing, slaw and biscuit. The cardboard box popped open like a magic jewel case. I sank my teeth into a greasy breast and heaved a sigh filled with tears.
当我终于抬起头时，我意识到餐馆里挤满了吃着鸡肉和比斯吉饼的日本人。在明亮的荧光灯下，他们津津有味地吮吸着骨头，舔着手指。那种兴奋感令人难以置信。当我把零食盒的成本从日元转换成美元时，我意识到按照这些价格，这是一个重大的夜晚。
When I finally looked up, I realized the restaurant was jam-packed with Japanese eating chicken and biscuits. In the bright fluorescent light, they sucked bones and licked their fingers with gusto. The excitement was unbelievable. And when I translated the cost of a snack box from yen to dollars, I realized that at these prices, this was a serious night out on the town.
突然，鸡肉的味道在我嘴里变酸了。日本人相信上校。他们认为是他发明了这个食谱。我愤怒得麻木了。“这是我的。我的，”我想尖叫。黑人奴隶发明了这个食谱。你认为那个白人老头站在木炉子边炸鸡？我看着一张张脸，脑子里尖叫的声音。我想要他们的感激。我想要他们对这些油腻微笑的赞赏。“看看我，”我想喊。“我就是那11种草药和香料。我就是那个秘密食谱。”周围，人们笑着、咂嘴着、舔着手指。在京都夜晚的黑暗中，上校明亮洁白的雕像像灯塔一样闪耀。
Suddenly, the taste of the chicken went sour in my mouth. The Japanese believe in the Colonel. They think he invented this recipe. I was numb with fury. "This is mine. Mine," I wanted to scream. Black slaves invented this recipe. You think that old white man stood over a wood stove frying chicken? I looked from face to face, the voice screaming inside of my brain. I wanted their gratitude. I wanted credit for their greasy smiles. "Look at me," I wanted to shout. "I'm the 11 herbs and spices. I'm the secret recipe." All around, people were laughing and smacking and licking their fingers. And in the dark of the Kyoto night, the bright white statue of the Colonel shone like a beacon.
然后我意识到另一件事。这个上校毁了我的世界和其中的一切。现在，跟着我。这就是我想说的。我说的是要理解过去40年的历史，你必须理解鸡肉的历史。肯德基消灭了一种生活方式，摧毁了一种文化。曾经在美国，每个黑人女性都有她自己的秘密食谱。但没人再炸鸡了，当他们能用8块钱买到一个桶时。
Then I realized something else. This Colonel had destroyed my world and everything in it. Now, follow me here. This is what I'm trying to say. I'm saying that to understand the history of the last 40 years, you have to understand the history of chicken. Kentucky Fried Chicken has wiped out a way of life, destroyed a culture. It used to be that every black woman in America had her own secret recipe. But nobody fries chicken anymore, not when they can pick up a bucket for eight.
最重要的是，鸡肉晚餐是地下经济的基础。需要几块额外美元吗？卖晚餐。我们经历了一场大规模的敌意收购。整晚打扫办公室、白天卖晚餐的教会女性，她们养活了我们，让我们的教堂没有抵押贷款。我们忘记了我们的食谱。再来几年的上校，恐怕我们什么都记不起来了。
And on top of that, chicken dinners were the foundation of an underground economy. Need a few extra dollars? Sell dinners. We've experienced a hostile takeover of enormous proportions. Church women who cleaned offices all night and sold dinners all day, they fed us and left our churches mortgage-free. We've forgotten our recipes. And a few more years of the Colonel, and I'm afraid we might not remember anything.
Cassandra Smith。
Cassandra Smith.
第五幕，了解你的肉。这是一首Lisa Buscani的诗。
Act Five, Know Your Meat. This is a poem by Lisa Buscani.
我记得红肉。在红肉的时代，我们的生活充满胜利的斑纹。脂肪意味着赢，我们有弹性的空间。手指的肉折叠在我们的神圣戒指上，埋没我们的眼睛，加倍我们的微笑。在红肉的时代，我们把它重重地拍进煎锅、烤箱、烤盘，通过磨碎机。
I remember red meat. In red meat's time, our lives were marbled with victory. Fat meant winning, and we had room for bounce. The flesh of our fingers folded over our sacred rings, burying our eyes and doubling our smiles. In red meat's time, we slapped it down to fry pans, to roasters, to broilers, through grinders.
跳过那些撒谎、渗出的表面吧。那就是生活。那就是死亡。事情就是这样。事情一直都是这样。没坏就别修它。我会给你一个哭泣的理由。
Skip the lying, seeping, surface. That's life. That's death. That's the way it is. That's the way it's always been. If it ain't broke, don't fix it. And I'll give you something to cry about.
那时的男人是男人，女人是泡沫。毛茸茸的，兔子的，泡沫的。不可思议地被烧焦，雪纺，咯咯笑，泡沫。大腿高，长线，尼龙，带我去里约的泡沫。原谅我们去扑粉。[喘气]
The men then were men, and the women were bubbly. Fuzzy, bunny, bubbly. Impossibly singed, chiffon, giggling, bubbly. Thigh-high, long-line, nylon, fly-me-to-Rio bubbly. Excuse us while we powder our nose. [GASP]
在下面和后面，交易达成，细节你不应该知道，用罕见的红肉紧纤维密封，配以烈性的金酒、不自然的笑声和祈祷。男人们在铺满软垫的椅子上挪动，害怕又爱着他们作为男子气概牛排的与生俱来的权利，敬畏的烤肠蜷缩在肠组织下打了一个又一个长长的盹。
And in the under and the back, deals were made featuring details you shouldn't know about sealed with the tight fiber of rare, red meat chased with hard, gold liquor, unnatural laughter, and prayer. And the men shifted in the overstuffed chairs, fearing and loving their birthrights as manly steaks, and godly brats snuggled under intestinal tissue for a long, long nap.
那是科学，摧毁了结束它的身体知识。向我们展示我们的心脏如何过早停止，我们的结肠如何被长途旅行的残余物塞得坚硬如石，我们的静脉如何充满了坏脂肪。教育、哭泣、嘎嘎作响和对替代品的渴求，所以我们寻找其他东西在牙齿间撕扯。
It was science, blasted bodies of knowledge that ended it. Showing us how our hearts stopped too soon, our colons packed rock-solid with the remnants of grand tours, our veins viscous with bad fats. Educations, cries, rattle, and gnash for alternatives, so we searched for other stuffs to tear between our teeth.
进入海洋的果实。长鳍金枪鱼、对虾、鳕鱼、剑鱼和比目鱼，它们在我们的盘子里显得轻盈、油腻且酸涩。在海鲜的时代，我们走得小心翼翼。我们走路时几乎能听到风铃的声音。世界是米色的，木头是金色的，加州把它通风的触角伸向了一切。我们融化成骨架的角度，把人工混合物涂在背上， stalking着强制性的派对。
Enter the fruits of the sea. The albacores, prawn, cods, swordfish, and soles that lay light and oily and sour on our plate. In seafood's time, we tread lightly. You could almost hear the wind chimes when we walked. The world was beige, the wood was blond, and California had its airy tentacles in everything. We melted down to skeletal angles, laid artificial blends on our backs, and stalked the mandatory party.
在海鲜的时代，男人是男人，女人是阴郁的。直发和素颜，她们厌倦了等待属于她们的那份虾。任何男性的微笑都被嗅探并怀疑是性别歧视。姐妹们以前被骗过。女人退回到书本中，退到低级办公桌后，等待她们平等出现的那一刻，就像蝴蝶折回茧中寻找更大的翅膀。有些男人，被女孩们的离去震惊了，长出了鬓角，疯狂地奔跑以腾出空间。其他人心怀不满地滚开了，把尖锐的尾巴猛击在多变的地面上，希望从反弹中得到什么。
In seafood's time, men were men and the women were sullen. Straight-haired and bare-faced, they grew tired of waiting for their share of the shrimp. Any male smile was sniffed and suspected of sexism. Sisters had been fooled before. Women pulled back into books and behind low-level desks, waiting for the moment when they would emerge equal, like the butterfly folding back to cocoon in search of a greater wing. Some men, shaken by the loss of their girls, grew sideburns and frantically ran to make room. Others rumbled away disgruntled, slamming their spiked tails against a volatile ground in the hope that something would come from the backlash.
在禅宗的懦弱中，我们放弃了对错，边缘渗入了灰色。性变成了颤抖和运动。在那个时代，用眼睛看得太硬太乱太沉重。很快，我们发现海鲜粘在壳上比粘在肋骨上多，而且它的骨头一直是个问题。在内陆地区，它从来不便宜，而且烹饪需要太长时间，在疯狂、残酷的水中挣扎着死亡。
The edge bled into gray as we abandoned right or wrong in Zen cowardice. The sex was shudder and exercise. Looking hard to the eye was far too messy and heavy for the time. And soon, we discovered that seafood stuck more to its shells than to our ribs, and its bones were always a problem. It was never cheap in a land-locked region and took too long to cook, thrashing its death throes in mad, cruel water.
所以我们重新开始，寻找不会留下伤疤的食物。于是家禽来了。轻盈且令人满足，奇迹般地多才多艺。毕竟，不是所有的东西都渴望尝起来像它吗？家禽无私地把自己献给我们，完美地融入我们所有的菜肴中。在生活中，这些喙是卑鄙的、突出的怪物。但在死亡中，裸露着从脚踝悬挂，家禽体贴地确保我们的血液畅通无阻地泵动。
So we began again, looking for the food that wouldn't scar us. And along came poultry. Light and filling, miraculously versatile. After all, didn't everything else aspire to taste like it? Poultry gave itself up to us selflessly, blending perfectly in all our dishes. In life, these beaks were mean, jutting little monsters. But in death, nude and hanging from its ankles, poultry was considerate enough to see that our blood kept pumping unobstructed.
在家禽的时代，我们的体重回到了可承受的范围内，但并没有那么严重。有了它的燃料，我们努力奔向我们想要的。世界是——世界是——好吧，我们不记得世界看起来像什么了。我们从没停下来足够长的时间让它从模糊中聚焦。
In poultry's time, we filled back to livable weights, but not grossly so. And with its fuel, we ran hard at what we wanted. The world was-- the world was-- well, we can't remember what the world looked like. We never stopped long enough for it to focus from its blur.
在家禽的时代，男人是男人，女人是男人。检查肌肉结构。看看耐力。我们看着女人们和男人们一样撕裂胃粘膜。难道她们的头不是为了第四季度的数字和生孩子的余波吗？难道她们的笑声不是最虚假的丝绸，很像她们作为最后一点性欲象征戴的围巾吗？吻吻孩子，递过辣椒粉，还有工作要做。
In poultry's time, the men were men and the women were men. Check the musculature. See the stamina. We watched as women tore up stomach lining with the best of them. Weren't their heads for fourth quarter figures and baby-making afterthoughts? Wasn't their laughter the most false silk, much like the scarves they wore as their last shred of sex? Kiss the kids and pass the paprikash, there was work to be done.
男人们，感到匆忙和被超越，溜进了僵硬、圆滑的意大利数字里，一群无血的Pat Rileys。他们开始向下寻找模特，不屑于按照他们不断改变的规则行事。我跟你赌一个Boesky，加两个Trump。
And the men, feeling rushed and outrun, slipped into hard, sleek, Italian numbers, legions of bloodless Pat Rileys. They began to look downward for their models, not bothering to play by rules they kept changing. I'll bet you a Boesky and raise you two Trumps.
在家禽的时代，猪肉试图提出这样的主张，像一个唠叨的小兄弟一样跺着脚。“我是白肉。教练，让我上。”但我们不会被动摇。以羊肉乌托邦的名义，我们热爱的是家禽。直到我们发现它是如何被清洗的。或者更确切地说，它是如何没被清洗的。沙门氏菌的故事和其他野兽般的细菌。Jim Fixx在慢跑中像苍蝇一样倒下。没有什么是看起来的那样。所有的承诺都躺在基座底部破碎了。
In poultry's time, pork made a stab at such a claim, stamping its feet like a naggy little brother. "I'm white meat. Put me in, coach." But we would not be swayed. In the name of an ovine utopia, it was poultry that we loved. Until we found out how it was cleaned. Or rather, how it wasn't cleaned. Salmonella stories and other beastly bacteria. Jim Fixx dropped like a fly in mid-jog. Nothing was ever what it seemed. And all promises lay shattered at the pedestal's base.
现在我们漫无目的地从一种食物游荡到另一种食物。没有什么能像我们曾经知道的那样满足我们。意大利面是一个偶尔的朋友，它的数量让我们厌烦。我们似乎永远无法把蔬菜从配菜中带过来。我们的选择像春天的冰一样融化，我们正在滑向旧世界的贫困。
Now we wander listlessly from food to food. Nothing fills us like we once knew. Pasta is a sometime friend that bores us with its quantity. And we can never seem to bring the vegetable over from the side dish. Our options are melting like spring ice, and we are slipping to old-world poverties.
男人和女人正缓慢地从他们各自的山上走下来。“对不起。真的，为一切感到抱歉。我是认真的。”他们正在回忆彼此脸上的善良，仁慈的皮肤和骨头。这里的静电和干扰少了那么多，我们现在有时间了。我们能再试一次吗？如果你仔细听，你可以听到改革后的、含蓄的红肉在拍打我们生存的门。
Men and women are coming down slowly from their separate mountains. "Sorry. Really, sorry for everything. I mean it." They are remembering the goodness in each other's faces, benevolent skin and bone. There is so much less static and distraction, and we have time now. Can't we try again? And if you listen closely, you can hear the reticent, reformed tapping of red meat at our survival's door.
“嗨。我刚好在附近。‘瘦肉’和‘散养’这两个词对任何人意味着什么吗？给我另一个机会。你不能吗？”
"Hi. I was in the neighborhood. Don't the words 'lean' and 'free range' mean anything to anyone? Give me another chance. Can't you?"
[音乐 - Roy Brown的“BUTCHER PETE”]
[MUSIC - "BUTCHER PETE" BY ROY BROWN]
Lisa Buscani，一位现在住在波士顿的芝加哥诗人。天哪，那首歌真讨厌。
Lisa Buscani, a Chicago poet who now lives in Boston. Man, that song is nasty.
好了，我们今天的节目由Alix Spiegel和Nancy Updike、Peter Clowney和我本人制作。特约编辑，Paul Tough、Jack Hitt和Margy Rochlin。我只是在切换音乐。
Well, our program produced today by Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike, Peter Clowney and myself. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. I'm just switching music here.
[致谢]
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
如果你想要这个节目的备份，只要10美元。致电WBEZ订购。312-832-3380。312-832-3380。我们做的所有节目都有磁带版本。我们的电子邮件地址，[email protected] 。
If you would like a copy of this program, it's only $10. Call us at WBEZ to order that. 312-832-3380. 312-832-3380. All of the shows we do are available on cassette. Our email address, [email protected] .
[赞助商致谢]
[FUNDING CREDITS]
WBEZ管理监督，Torey Malatia。我是Ira Glass——
WBEZ management oversight by  Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass--
你好。又是我。2006年。那几乎就是该节目的全部备份了。希望你们喜欢它。
Hi. Me again. 2006. That's pretty much all we have of that show. I hope you enjoyed it.
嗨，又是我。2006年。关于那个节目我们大概就只有这么多了。希望你们喜欢。